you LeBron
5-0 was a captain I mean we've been
doing this thing for five years and I
still remember the first time it was you
and Steph and what did you tell me when
we were trying to figure out how this
had gone
what did I tell you you said it's got to
be on TV got to be on TV yeah got to be
on TV and uh we got to the point where
now it's on TV and now we're doing it
like playground style so that's pretty
cool 5-0 what's been the secret
um
I just always pick a good thing does it
have something to do with what's on this
sheet of paper over here
no no this ain't nothing can I see that
tissue this is tissue hey hey look
tissue you've got a you've got a sheet
of paper y'all just got a book over here
look at this
gonna
okay yeah yeah that's a LeBron
that looks that doesn't look bad right
there thank you but but who am I
um anyway Euro and two as a captain
against this cat and you told me the
other night I said how much are you
thinking about this
foreign
put a lot of thought behind it but at
the end of the day as I've said in the
past like you can't go wrong the 24th of
the best players in the world so
whatever Pika I choose tonight like it's
going to be a great team we'll go get a
win they'll go try to take a big fella
down and and one other thing I
unless you'd like to respond
I see you taped up a little bit here we
saw the other night that you uh you hurt
your right wrist in the last game before
the break so uh what's your status for
tonight
uh whatever I have I'm gonna give that's
that's who I am
um
that's not Never Gonna Change all right
okay so he'll play the full 48. okay so
um
you have the first pick of the reserves
Giannis and uh the floor is yours I
can't wait to see if you follow the book
my first pick yeah
what'd you say LeBron
I already known his first fish that's so
do I
my first pick going to be they mean
wow
on the playground I would never pick you
to give it to your broadcast Blazers 31
a night
and here's the uh the first pick by look
that surprised me too
no you're not gonna you're not gonna do
him dirty here are you no you're not
see Giannis has changed this weekend I
think so too you know he always talk
about loyalty to being loyal I know all
that stuff right
so I knew for sure his first pick
was gonna be Drew so I don't know what's
going on with y'all okay okay messed my
whole draft board up now
with my first pick
I'm gonna go with
Anthony Edwards
okay this is interesting
you know yeah
Anthony Edwards 21 years old and by the
way Anthony go dogs
foreign
so your guy is still up there
be honest you got the next pick
so
um my second pick is going to be drew a
holiday
[Applause]
[Music]
that makes it right great teammate make
it quick
that makes it right I think that makes
it right you know of course
it's a great leader and it's also a
great basketball player
finds US put us in the right spots but
defensively it's just a nightmare and uh
major reason the Bucks number two in the
East just a half game behind Boston for
the best record in the Eastern
Conference all right LeBron
my second pick
of the draft
is uh Jalen Brown
[Applause]
second All-Star appearance
and it went what a year career high in
points rebounds and field goal
percentage given the Celtics about 26 a
night you want to explain some of your
reasoning here LeBron and forever how
you construct your team yeah you know
I've got to have a lot of Youth a lot of
athleticism and some shop making you
gotta have some shot making on this team
in this game so uh starting off pretty
good so far
he's happy with where he is I'm sure you
are too but let's go to pick number
three so my third big
is gonna be one of the most exciting
rising star superstar in the league
right now John Moran
I hate to I hate to break it to you but
he's started
what's up what oh you talk about
somebody's draft board being the same
you see what I'm saying see what I'm
saying he trying anything y'all y'all is
just trying anything y'all
[Applause]
so uh let's go back so let's go another
Direction so
uh my third big then so let me pass this
out comes the pen
so my my third be gonna be safe
[Applause]
[Music]
first time All-Star
fourth player from Canada to be an
All-Star
33 games of at least 30 points
and look he's played 53 games he's been
the Thunder's leading scorer in 47 of
those
so SGA
it took a while but he goes to Giannis
okay LeBron use are you straight on who
the starters and reserves are I believe
so okay go ahead you're up uh with my
third pick this is my third pick record
what is your third pick my third pick
because this is a family oriented
game I'm going to go with PG-13 Paul
George
23 points a game six rebounds five
assists and if you're into the metric
thing
and plus minus Clippers are plus 141
when he's on the floor and when he's off
minus 122. take that for data okay
are you good here is everything
everything's settled now everything's
good okay good everything is good I was
just excited to get Jeff oh
um so the this is my fourth pick right
it is
so with my fourth big
I'll pick DeMar DeRozan DeMar DeRozan
six-time All-Star
guy shooting 51 from the floor this year
13th scorer in the league all right
LeBron
with my fourth pick
I'm going to take
Tyrese Halliburton Tyrese salad for the
first timer
[Music]
20 points a game also number four an
assist number three and Steals and and
again a a young guy okay only 22 years
old all right how about it Giannis
with my fifth pick man my team looks
stacked right here man I love my team so
far uh with my fifth pick I'm gonna take
my African brother pasca hey
we're doing it for the motherland yeah
the highlight of his Season
52 with at the Garden seventh visit
Burger to ever go for more than 50. all
right
with my fifth pick
I'm taking the New York Knickerbocker
Julius Randle
Julius given the Knicks 25 and 11. and
here's what I love it's it's like
Anthony Edwards Julius randles played
every game this year all 60 for the New
York Knicks
getting down to it here as far as the
reserves go Giannis what you got
with my six pick
I'ma take a guy that I believe is one of
the hardest playing dude out there he
gives everything every single night for
his team in order for them to win Bama
Dubai
is up his scoring average every year of
his six years in the season 22-10 this
year yes LeBron with my sixth pick I'm
going with who I believe
is the fastest guy from Baseline to
Baseline D Aaron Fox
not only is he quick he's the NBA's
leader in clutch points this year all
right we got two more
so with myself pink right this is your
last pickup Reserves
I'm going with sabones the mother is so
bonus
an NBA leading shot clock yes you do you
have a chair and Jack we gotta play some
defense at some point let's go JJ
he's the league leader in blocks and
stops which is blocks plus Steals and so
there we go how you've how you feeling
right now Giannis after that round
I think I got a great team uh they're
gonna play hard and I think we're in a
very good place right now we're going to
get a double and you and you may still
have a chance to draft cha when it's
appropriate how do you feel I feel
really good about our team we got a lot
got a lot of Youth a lot of shop making
some play making got a got a defensive
presence in our last pick of the draft
which is huge so looking forward to it
so there you go the reserves have been
selected when we come back we'll get to
the starters and we'll also visit with
Charles Kenny and Shaq but watch anyway
we'll be back